et avec la multiplication des attentats
terroristes en europe la question
devient de plus en plus pressante que
faire pour empêcher que de tels tueries
se répète j'en ai parlé plus tôt avec
alain rodier il est directeur adjoint au
centre français de recherche sur le
renseignement
monsieur redit les terroristes ont
réussi à frapper au coeur de l'europe au
coeur de la capitale européenne qu'est
ce que ça nous dit sur la force du
groupe armé état islamique
eh bien ça prouve que cette organisation
est une puissance il faut bien savoir
que bon les autorités n'aiment pas la
nommer comme ça mais c'est un état c'est
l'état islamique et donc il agit avec
toute la puissance d'un état qui
contrôlent à peu près 8 millions de
personnes
il a une administration il lui manque
qu'un seul ministère d'ailleurs c'est
celui des affaires étrangères
mais il a une capacité d'action
extrêmement importante et il a été
décidé par ce gouvernement aurait été
qu'on appelle la choura le conseil
consultatif il a été décidé donc au
printemps dernier de passer à des
actions extérieures au noyau cire ou
irakiens qui constitue donc l'état
islamique parce que effectivement de sur
ce champ de bataille l'état islamique
commencé à connaître des revers
certainement pas une défaite mais des
revers et donc de façon à desserrer un
peu l'étau il a été décidé au printemps
de l'année dernière de passer à l'action
à l'étranger ça s'est traduit par la
première tragédie qui a été celle du
l'airbus russe de sharm el sheikh et ça
s'est poursuivi par une suite
d'attentats
à beyrouth paris et puis maintenant
bruxelles
mais c'est une affaire extrêmement
coordonnées voulu évidemment la question
aujourd'hui c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour se protéger contre cette
forme de terrorisme est ce que est ce
qu'on met les moyens nécessaires le
risque zéro avec le terroriste n'existe
pas j'ai toujours tendance à prendre en
exemple l'état d'israël qui est un état
extrêmement policiers avec les meilleurs
services secrets du monde le mossad avec
des politiques qui appuient leurs
services
quant au cube pour pas dire qui les
couvrent dans toutes les actions qui
peuvent mener dont des opérations
d'élimination physique à l étranger et
bien même cet état qui n'est pas très
important en taille et qui est
extrêmement contrôlée et bien arrive à
laisser passer des terroristes qui mène
des actions régulièrement sur sur le
territoire israélien
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
renforcer la sécurité aux frontières par
exemple en europe
est ce que c'est la solution à ce que
c'est suffisant bon il est vrai que
puisque le nous ne contrôlons plus les
frontières à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen en particulier eh bien il faut
envisager un renforcement des contrôles
aux frontières extérieures
mais techniquement parlant cela
nécessite des personnels supplémentaires
des matériels supplémentaires et en
particulier des liaisons avec les
fichiers qui peuvent permettre
d'identifier des personnes qui ont déjà
été repérés ça nécessite également des
contrôles plus accrue et qui ne sont pas
forcément apprécié de l'ensemble des
habitants de l'europe dont qui va voir
aussi une action psychologique a menée
vis-à-vis des dirigeants et des
populations parce que le premier droit
des citoyens c'est de vivre en sécurité
mais certainement aux dépens de
l'abandon d'un petit peu de cette
sacro-sainte liberté individuelle mais
ce qu'il faut se concentrer sur ce qui
se passe en
gic parce qu'on sait maintenant sans
rencontre jour après jour que c'est
devenu un centre du radicalisme musulman
dont la belgique jeu il suffit de
regarder une carte géographique mans a
toujours été un carrefour pour toutes
les activités illégales
les premières c'est le crime organisé
qui toujours été réputé passé par la
belgique pour se livrer un certain
nombre d'activités sur tout le
territoire européen
le terrorisme également à trouver dans
la belgique un refuge une zone de de
repos où ils pouvaient l'été les
activistes pouvait trouver des
conditions de façon adéquate de façon à
se renouveler à pouvoir préparer leur
affaire et l'a peut-être ont-ils commis
une erreur parce que en frappant la
belgique et bien il oblige les autorités
belges ont renforcé par l'aide de leurs
collègues européens à passer à l'action
et maintenant donc à terme ils vont
perdre cette base logistique parce que
tout le monde
le sur tout le monde politique s'est
rendu compte que c'était absolument
intolérable donc ils ont peut-être dans
notre malheur mais ils ont peut-être mal
jouer vis-à-vis d'eux mêmes et par
rapport à aux forces policières belge
est ce qu a eu des failles de ce côté là
d'après vous comment est ce que tu te la
police était sur le qui-vive et n'a pas
réussi à prévenir ces attentats alors je
ne partage pas du tout le monde appelle
belge bashing qui a été très à la mode
ces dernières semaines mais seulement
les services belges de police de
renseignements sont à la taille du pays
c'est un petit pays et certainement pas
à la taille de la menace représentée par
le terrorisme international et donc il
faut que les services étrangers qu opère
encore plus étroitement avec les
services belges pour leur apporter toute
l'aide dont ils ont besoin pour faire
face à cette menace donc peut-être
renforcer le contrôle aux frontières
mais aussi
cette rapidité des échanges
d'informations mais au-delà de ces
mesures la sk pas aussi de véritables
questions à se poser peut-être sur
l'inclusion ce sont des jeunes qui ont
qui se sont faits exposés sont des
jeunes belges qui ont tué d'autres beige
donc est ce qu elle pas aussi des
questions à se poser de ce côté là en
terminant alors il y a effectivement le
problème de la motivation qu'est ce qui
motive les les activistes de des groupes
salafistes djihadistes que ça soit
d'al-qaïda canal historique de lège
d'ailleurs il y a d'abord le noyau de
commandement un noyau extrêmement dur
qui est composée d'hommes qui sont
extrêmement verser dans la théologie
islamique qui connaissent très bien les
textes sacrés et qu'ils aient qu'ils
appliquent donc ces textes sacrés le
salafisme jihadiste je rappelle c'est un
retour à l'islam des origines tel qu'ils
le voient eux mêmes et une condamnation
donc de toutes les évolutions qui ont pu
avoir lieu après ceux là sont convaincus
maintenant les activistes dont nous
parlons les occidentaux et en
particulier les européens
beaucoup d'entre eux proviennent de la
criminalité organisée ou pas d'ailleurs
mais ont basculé dans le salafisme
djihadisme certainement pas pour leur
connaissance ce approfondie du coran
mais en réalité c'est une sorte de
révolte qui exprime à travers cette
cause soyons francs 30 ans en arrière il
aurait rejoint les mouvements
marc triste léniniste extrémistes ou
anarchistes parce que ce sont des gens
qui se révoltent contre leurs conditions
de vie du conte en europe et donc ils
ont choisi ce moyen pour se révolter
la nouveauté c'est que malheureusement
ils sont prêts à aller jusqu'au
sacrifice suprême c'est à dire que leur
mentor ont réussi à leur laver le
cerveau de telle façon qu'ils sont prêts
à aller jusqu'au bout et ça ça
commençait pas rentrer ça comment est-ce
qu'on 8 contre ça personnellement je
suis un petit peu pessimiste je vous le
dire je pense qu'il ya une génération
perdue parce que nous avons une
génération qui est donc à l'heure
actuelle rentrée en révolte contre la
génération précédente
on sait pas une nouveauté c'est une
honte on le connaît toutes époques et en
éviter cette génération elle sera très
difficile à récupérer à quand j'entends
parler de déradicalisation bien sûr
qu'il faut essayer mais personnellement
j'ai quelques doutes sur l'efficacité de
ces méthodes
en réalité le problème sera arrivé quand
y'aura la génération suivante c'est à
dire leurs enfants et bien rentreront en
révolte contre eux à leur tour et à ce
moment là
bon ce problème sera certainement régler
mais malheureusement je suis assez
pessimiste avec la génération de
djihadistes que nous avons à l'heure
actuelle bien alors pas de solution
facile merci beaucoup monsieur redis je
vous en prie